♪ ♪ ♪
- Le constat d'Alan Parks
est implacable : ni l'Alaska
ni les États-Unis ne sont prêts
climatiques.
L'homme a consacré sa vie
à la mer : d'abord comme pêcheur
commercial de saumon pendant
comme militant écologiste.
Pas besoin de lui rappelerrapper
que l'Alaska se réchauffe
de deux à quatre fois plus vite.
Le réchauffement climatique,
il l'a vu dans l'eau et
sur la terre ferme.
Alan Parks a pris sa retraiêchs
est désormais guide d'aventure.
À Homer, on lui doit l'adoption
du tout premier plan d'action
climatiqourd'hui,
force est d'admettre que
ce genre d'initiative locale
ne sera pas suffisante.
♪ ♪ ♪
En Alaska, l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques
par la protection du saumon.
Le poisson est non seulement
un moteur économique crucial;
identitaire fort et omniprésent.
"Le saumon est au coeur de la
vie en Alaska, dit Sue Mauger,
c'est aueurs dans eurs dans eure
profondément marquée
par la division."
Directrice scientifique
d'un organisme de on,
elle étudie les populations de
saumon depuis plus de 20 ans.
mais elle n'en demeure pas moins
sensible aux changements
climatiques. L'accélération du
la reproduction du poisson
le plus de l'État.
Dans ce contexte, pas
contexte, pas
surprenant que le changement
climatique soit devenu un enjeu
électoral dans cet Étatrerereree
est constant.
Louie Flora a passé toute
congrès d'État se décrit d'abord
et avanteur.
Plutôt que de choisir le camp
démocrate ou républicain, ilépe,
la seule façon, selon lui,
de vraiment faire avancer
les dossiers importants,
au coeur de sa campagne.
Les conséquences
du réchauffement sont connues.
À Homrès année, à voir
fondre le glacier Grewingk.
Mais l'Alaska a peut-être vécu
dans les dernières semaines
ces crabces crabces crabces crat
normalement être en mer,
mais la chute considérable
des populations de crabes,
du réchauffement de la mer,
a forcé l'Alaska
pour la première fois sa très
lucrative pêche d'hiver.nement s
impacts partout dans l'État",
croit Louie Flora.
L'Alaska a beau s
en plus le réchauffement, l'État
demeure un bastion conservateur.
fief de Sarah Palin, qui tente
un retour en polit
les changements climatiques
peuvent rapidement être balayés
électeurs.
- But I think it's just the way
of itself! We got to let God
- Aussi conservateur soit-il,À e
de l'Alaska, les r
l'urgence climatique sont bien
visibles, comme cette murale qui
s'est réchauffée depuis 100 ans.
Impossible d'ignorer l'enjeu,po,
les électeurs de l
choisi une démocrate en août
dernier, lors d'une élection
au Congrès.
Mary Pe Mary Pe Mary Pe Mary Pe
autochtone, occupe le seul
siège de l'État à la Chambre
des représentants et tente
maintenant d'obten
Sa récente victoire constitue
ration
pour l'Alaska Center, un groupe
de pression progressiste,
les niveaux des politicienss dut
comme Mary Peltola.
"Les candidats en Alaskade plus
difficilement nier les impacts
du réchauffement", souligne
Même les leaders conservateurs
ont commencé à en parler, signe
qu'ici, ns en moins
partisane entre démocrateset ré.
La caus
a beau gagner des appuis,
la réponse à l'urgence
Les échéanciers climatiquesoraus
été aussi peu compatibles,
Pour réussir le coup de
barre nécessaire, une lutte
d'ampleu
barre nécessaire, une lutted'am,
estime Alan Parks.
Le capitaine a beau être habitué
aux intempéries, la tempête
climatique en cours est celle
qui l'effraie le plus